حوار ليبي الليبي يجمع اطراف الازمه في
البلاد لتجاوز حاله الركود والانسداد
السياسي الحالي هذا هو الهدف الرئيسي من
مبادره مبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا عبد الله
باتيلي لاجراء الانتخابات نهايه هذا العام
من خلال خريطه طريق تكون جاهزه مع حلول
منتصف يونيو حزيران القادم
تتمثل هذه المبادره في تشكيل ما سماها
باتيل لجنه رفيعه المستوى تختارها اطراف
الازمه الليبيه بما فيها مجلس النواب
والاعلى للدوله ولا دخل للامم المتحده في
تشكيلها تقود التفاوض مباشره بين اطراف
الازمه او من خلال ممثلي هذه الاطراف في
اللجنه
ان الفريق رفيع المستوى على النحو الذي
قدمته لكم لا علاقه له باي حل المفروض من
الخارج ولا يتجاوز الاطراف او المؤسسات
الليبيه بل يشملهم جميعا كما شدد بتيري
على ضروره اطلاق حوارات بين الاجهزه
العسكريه والامنيه في كافه انحاء البلاد
للاتفاق على ضمان امن الانتخابات توالت
ردود الفعل المحليه على مبادره باتيلي
فرئيس الحكومه راها متسقه مع مواقف سابقه
قال فيها ان عدم اجراء الانتخابات سببه ما
وصفه بقصور الجهات التشريعيه عن ايجاد
قوانين ق للتنفيذ وعادله ونزيهه كنا نتمنى
اليوم في هذا اللقاء الصحفي ان تكون
مبادره واضحه المعالم واضحه الجداول ولكن
اليوم عندما تحدث وقال مجلس الاعلى للدوله
مجلس النواب يعني قال تلتحق مؤخرا احسن من
لا تلتحق اعتقد ان هذه مؤشرات صراحه الى
مازال الوضع كما هو عليه في الوقت الراهب
تهدف مهمه المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا
لانهاء المسارات المتعثره للازمه الليبيه
بانتخابات نهايه هذا العام وتلك مهمه لا
شك ستواجه بتحديات عده ابرزها مواقف
الاطراف المحليه المدعومه من دول اقليميه
عرفت بلعب ادوار رئيسيه في تطورات الازمه
منذ سنوات
احمد خليفه الجزيره من داخل مقر البعثه
الامميه في ليبيا طرابلس